make big decisions with your heart big
decisions with the heart small ones with
the head at the beginning when you're
trying to decide what to do your head
and your heart often will fight they'll
conflict they won't be aligned because
your head only understands a world that
currently exists it's safe it's
practical it's logical it knows what
currently exists well your heart can
create something brand new your heart
can imagine something that's never
existed before and they Clash at the
beginning your heart wants to go do this
thing but you don't know how it's going
to work out cuz it doesn't make sense
cuz nobody's done it before and
especially someone who looks like you
with youron resources and your education
your background and your connections and
your financial situation nobody like you
has ever done it before that's what your
head's saying and so this is big fight
you need to take control of the
situation you need to get them aligned
by saying this is what I'm doing big
decisions with the heart